- We are back with Tim Allen, everybody!
(crowd cheering)
That was a look at his
new show on Disney Plus,
it's called the Santa Clauses.
And we are also joined by
his very talented co-star
and real life daughter
now, Elizabeth Allen Dick.
Y'all give it up for her.
(crowd cheers)
You did so great!
And I was telling you in the
commercial, but I had no idea,
I didn't put it together
that you were his daughter,
until literally reading
the script for the show.
And I was like, "No way!"
I was like, anyway, You
did such a great job.
Was it intimidating or
weird to work with your dad?
- Um, not really, honestly.
It was a blast.
Like, I had so much fun
on set and off screen.
Like, we would finish
a scene he would just
immediately crack a joke about the scene,
and we would just start laughing.
But it was just a blast.
It was so much fun.
- I, I love this.
It's such a cool experience
to have like with your kid,
like enjoying something
that you love doing.
Was it weird for you?
- Well, I, I, I always set it up,
Her mom and I...
we're neutral about her
being in this business.
She's really good at school.
She's really good in athletics at school,
She's really good at math, and
she's a really good student.
- Yeah.
- And then for when the Santa
Claus, we decided to do this,
there's a lot of elves in it
and I wanted to make her an elf
as a joke, not a joke,
but if, Happy Christmas,
you're gonna go on set,
and just put on the
ears and wave at Santa.
So we'll have, have as a memory.
- Yeah.
- You know, and I,
- Great memory.
- thought about my older
daughter putting in there,
but elves at 32 years
old seems a little odd.
So, we just...
- Would've been funny.
And we put her in there and she said,
they said, uh,
if she says hi, she has to read.
We gotta get her voice done.
I said, I, I'm the executive
producer and I'm saying I don't
want to, nepotist on the side...
I don't want to push that.
- Yeah.
- And they go, "No, just have her read it.
We'll just read the
little part we got here."
She read it and the whole
room got real quiet.
And I went, "Wow."
And I heard everybody go, "Hmm,
has she done this before?"
And I go, "No, but I listen,
let's read all the other girls.
Let's just move on. Move on."
- Yeah.
- And she kept reading up the food chain,
and at one of the best
moments was she read it
against the studio and all
the big casting people,
the whole, the whole
place got really quiet.
It was on a Zoom audition.
- Yeah.
- And all the boxes literally
were looking at my box.
And I, I go, "Uhhhh."
And I was doing a fist pump
'cause she got the joke.
It was a really subtle
joke with her Mrs. Clause.
- Yeah.
And on the way through it, I
was on the road and she called,
they called her and her
mom at the home and said,
"We'd like her to be the lead."
I said, "I have no way to
describe how, had, she earned it.
She did it and she showed
great respect for the crew
and the staff and she just drilled it."
So...
- That's awesome.
I love that story.
'Cause a lot of people would think
that you just put her in there,
but she worked her way
up doing the reading.
- [Tim] Worked her way up and did it.
- And I love that you were
like, she got the joke.
I'm like, obviously you're her dad.
How does she not get jokes at this point?
Like, that would be weird.
But what's the, what's the
show about for everybody?
My, I was telling him,
me and my kids, we loved,
we saw two episodes so far.
It's so great.
We love the movies as well.
So, it was so great to see it as a series.
Like, what is it about, who do you play?
- So, I play Sandra
Claus, Santa's daughter.
And I feel like it's,
it starts to dive deep
into the family and Santa's
family and how his job can get
in the way of family time and
how it really, I mean it does.
And there's also, people
talk about this more,
but it answers the questions
that in the old Santa movies,
that people kind of started asking about
and that you didn't really ever find out.
So there's, you know, like
why weren't the elves mad when
just a new Santa arrived?
- I show up at the North
Pole and they're going,
"Okay, you gotta get
these package in here."
And you're thinking,
"Did the other guy die?
Did anybody care about what happened?"
- I loved that part actually.
- Well it's...
- Because it was weird in the movie!
The elves were like,
"Well he died, he's done."
Like, yeah.
- Did, did he die?
- Yeah. We don't know. I know.
- We don't know, we'll find out.
And we go dive deep as it gets later about
St. Nicholas and the Turkish
priest that started this.
So it, it honors the heart
of Christmas is about giving.
It's really important to understand,
getting is what we've got used to.
- Receiving. Yeah, yeah.
- Receiving.
But the whole thing is about
what it's like to give.
And boy, give is a, a
father to his children
and give to a giver and
the gift, gift getters.
- Yeah.
- It is so magic.
I said I wouldn't have done it.
Got back in that, that suit just,
- Oh my God. It has to be.
- She saw that.
Ugh, I get so angry.
- So what is that like?
Walking on set and your dad's Santa?
- I mean, well the first time
it was, it was really amazing.
And I just see him and
he comes around with the
whole suit on and the,
the full head, the beard,
the everything and, and
everyone's just kinda like,
up against the walls
like this, and just like,
looking at him.
- Isn't it incredible
what costumes do? Yeah.
- It's incredible.
- Transformative.
- It's like he's a different person.
But it was, it was really heartwarming
at the same time, because it's like,
all of these people saw
him when they were kids,
you know, in the, in the old movies.
And then now he comes
back on set as Santa.
- Yeah.
- As the char, as the
character that he's created.
And it was just, it was insane.
- It's cool, it's
nostalgic, it's beautiful.
(crowd clapping)
And my, and, and kids forever.
That's the cool thing about
doing Christmas stuff,
is like, each year, you gain
new fans that are old enough
to like start watching them.
Like even my kids are six and eight
and they've been watching it
for like, a couple years now.
And they, they, 'cause most
of the time they're like,
"I don't wanna watch a real people movie."
They're always like, "I
don't want real people."
But they love, they love
the Santa Claus movie.
So, they were really into watching it
and it was, it was just really well done.